social let's talk first about Victory
Day it is a big day every year in Russia
but it's paired down this year isn't it
it is a massively paired down it is
usually huge both in red square and
Moscow but also across the country but
they've canceled all of the uh parades
outside uh the the capital Russia has
lost a huge amount of military equipment
percentage up to two-thirds of its uh
tanks it's lost 50 the territory it once
owned and therefore that probably
explains why it's canceling some of this
but also one of the reasons is that this
parade which is the Immortals regiment
it's members of uh Russia who've lost
loved ones or relatives in the second
world war or or that campaign they carry
a picture uh on Parade last year
um uh President Putin carried a picture
of his father in uniform and led it the
trouble is this year they're really the
their authorities are really concerned
that loads of Ukrainian
um that people have lost their families
in the war in Ukraine and that will
explode expose the true level of losses
and so Russia's being paranoid to try
and cancel this element it's also noting
actually though that Ukraine although
this this war is about the millions they
lost Ukraine per capita lost more people
in that war against Nazi Germany than
Russia did and as a result Ukraine also
has its own Victory Day and that day is
today and part of the reason why we
think we're seeing this uptick in
activity is uh just to combat any
Ukrainian celebrations But the irony
here is Russia said that it was invading
Ukraine to denacify it and yet both
countries are celebrating Victory Day
because they they beat the Nazis okay
interesting and we had that air alert
across the whole of Ukraine this morning
and Russia have been active in recent
days haven't they they have for the last
10 days there's been a massive upswing
in the number of attacks we haven't been
covering the last couple of days because
obviously the coronation but for the
last 24 hours there were 35 uh one three
six drones these um drones that come
from Iran that the Russia bought and
have been hitting targets now Ukraine
are getting very good at targeting those
and knocking them out to the sky but 16
missiles were also fired and 6 61
airstrikes across the country and they
were all acquainted car keys mikhaila
Odessa and in Hearthstone in fact you
know in the the Kiev the mayor there
Klitschko said that five civilians were
were injured in one of the attacks but
when you see it some of the these don't
look like military targets do they they
this is a civilian block of flats and
one of the floors has just been
completely taken out of it and likewise
in Odessa they have targeted a Food
Warehouse which was Blazing away uh
again if you recall the the Russians
were targeting
um energy infrastructure across the
country it looks like they've shifted to
food which is a very worrying
development but as you say Airaid across
the whole country so they're obviously
Ukraine is expecting more of the same
today
let's talk about what I mentioned it in
the intro to all of this it would have
been if you're looking at it from
Putin's point of view would have been an
ideal situation for him to win that and
then celebrate Victory Day but it's been
very difficult isn't it and it just
isn't turning into the big victory that
he thought it would be no and there's so
11 months we've been talking about this
probably over a hundred thousand
casualties by some estimates and it's
become a bit of a meat grinder now
Russia does control about 90 percent of
the city of bakmut now
um and as you say would have been
provided a great empiric victory for
Putin but out to the Southwest there
that sort of eight o'clock position the
504 is the resupply route that is still
able to be operated and what the Russian
army is doing at the moment is around
the top and the bottom they're trying to
encircle and the Wagner group are active
in the middle of of the city but of
course there's been very highly
publicized friction between the Russian
army and the wagon group that ammunition
that seems to be resolved now but the
irony here and the really sad bit for a
military perspective is way back moot
Ukraine has made that a stand and when
asked about it they said well we've got
to reduce the size of Russian forces
we'll kill them somewhere and actually
if they're going to throw themselves at
our guns at seven to one casually rates
we'll do it here it turns out like this
week progressing yet guinea pig goes in
the boss of the Wagner group has said
that Russia is doing exactly the same
thing so you've got both sides the
tragediest war both sides uh in a
grinding War of Attrition for a city
that neither of them think matters too
much but both sides are just trying to
maximize the number of casualties they
inflict on each other it's just part of
the horrors of War it's very difficult
to rationalize and the massive loss of
human life and Devastation for what
purpose